[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of rissa fury i'm so excited today
because i have on
one of the best people on the planet
he's an amazing comedian we've done
stand-ups doing makeup together
got quite a a web history if you want to
look up our stuff
sean patton yay
but don't do that don't spin you know no
spinning absolutely it's the first thing
you learn
no spinning where did you learn this
bulgarian rules
he looked like he would have played
facebook well no i want to drag
i learned from a bulgarian dude okay
there's like bulgarian rules
no spinning right and you can't score
from the back
wait yeah you can only score with your
strikers
which are these three in case you didn't
know i don't know if you knew she knew
what is that
what is happening bulgarian rules okay
but where did you meet this man at like
a penny
at a bar called uh wait what was it
called mini capellis
okay in slidell louisiana i was like 18.
when i was like
illegally drinking well louisiana you
can drink yeah yeah yeah but
like five you start drinking at five can
you legally
remain to be seen but yeah taught me
bulgarian roles which i've played my
entire life no spinning
i mean spinning just do people spin do
people no no no no
well i mean do people spend on this show
yeah on the show no
unless i mean sometimes people have been
down by so much and i'm like
just if that's what's gonna make it so
you don't kill yourself after
this episode do what you need to do but
in general the rules are no spinning i'm
gonna
i'm gonna go in general i'm going to add
to that and say if
losing a game of foosball
pushes you over the edge don't play that
game
you're not ready yeah yeah yeah you're
not in there other things you should do
before you're like
if i lose this it's over like come on
i've seen people spiral very quickly on
this show
they come in in a fine mood even people
who are like
i know i'm not gonna win but once it
starts it's like those juices get going
and they
they get upset if see that's people who
just have too high expectations in life
you think two that's people have been
pampered yeah
you know what i'm saying that's p that's
people who like whose mothers never told
them no
i'm not like i'm like probably naming
friends of ours i think it's like
friends of ours but
like i know here's the thing i know
factually
i'll bet money i'm going to lose this
game okay
but my goal hey
huh i used to lose it okay with grace
okay i'm gonna be the best loser you've
ever defeated
that's my goal that's a safe bet to make
what does that mean you're a lovely man
yeah we'll find out but these these
bulgarian rules that's
that's [ __ ] you can score from the
back you can i can score goalie to
goalie
absolutely yeah could you do that okay
because i thought of a
question because i thought it was based
on football
okay could that happen in actual soccer
i mean i don't know in the history of
time has a goalie
drop kicked it from one yeah
that's not the right sport for that guy
then he should be doing something way
more advantageous right
if you could kick in the whole way that
would be a if there ever if there is a
goalie
who has scored a goal contacting us we
got a voltage
yeah have you heard of the aerial shot
it's not possible so that's
what like you like in like getting you
say that like it's that's that harry
potter witchcraft and wizardry
what are you a slytherin i mean are you
talking you can kick you can do that
can you do that i can't do it i mean if
you if i set the ball
physically here okay that i might what
that's terrifying even oh i'm not i'm
gonna look like an
[ __ ] that you just did is the most
impressive thing i've ever seen in
foosball
i'm not gonna be able to do it but you
if you get the leverage right
and then you flip it that way you even
balanced it can i try that of course
the fact that you even like did this
it's not that hard with any sort of like
oh oh [ __ ]
i'm a new man are you hard right now
this is so exciting here we go okay
yeah you see no it can't wait but people
people can kick it so it's like ah
they kick it so hard that they can pin
it up and then do it anyway
you can score from the back okay deal so
bulgarian rules suspended we're going
where are you from again
from spokane washington we're going to
spokane rules spokane
we're going to spokane in the boonies
almost to idaho
very trash and you're from new orleans
new orleans louisiana okay yeah
this is good this is a good matchup i
feel well yeah yeah we'll we'll
you know i want to say this real quick
these plastic
guards on this foosball table are
revolutionary to me because i have been
have you been nut checking i've been
fupa checked which by the way the first
time i ever heard
fupa it was fat upper penis area
and then later first time i ever heard
it it was applied to me
so later when it became applied to women
i was like nah [ __ ] that
i'm the one to fat up her penis area he
broke because it was said in front of my
friend's mom
so he couldn't say dick or [ __ ] so why
don't you leave penis
so if there's two entries in urban
dictionary for fupa the other is just
see sean patton's yeah upper penis also
the first time i've ever heard milf
applied to me
it was man i'd like to [ __ ] but it
wasn't
like i wasn't the man okay it was just
man comma i'd like to [ __ ] that's so it
was
like someone commenting that they wanted
to [ __ ] and they were talking to me
so many sayings have been birthed from
your body apparently
just you've inspired
the motherly way you are the milf you
are
[Music]
okay so we're gonna play the first game
to five just a standard game
okay we'll see how it goes
knuckle cracks there's a lot i do that
usually to intimidate my opponent
i don't think we've seen somebody crack
their knuckles yet so also
you can put the ball in through here but
regulation play now is it
starts here on the five bar you're
supposed to touch two men wait a second
and then you can
move the ball forward so no just like
hitting it oh okay
interesting but that's just the only
time in the game that you have to do
that no wait how about this
question i think keep dwight shooting me
question
question yes do you uh because i knew a
lot of people
growing up who did this who started like
that with the strikers up
sure you can do that if you want to
score from your five bar straight away
okay but if you want to pass then it's
like you've got your three bar in
in the catching position i like see i
like the other thing that looks tacky
you know i mean it's just like
that's like a it's like a spoiler on a
car it's like what if this car is fast
you don't need the
dumb little tail pipe well it also gives
away what you're about to do
so a good player would not do that but
then they'd either like
lift it last minute or just make sure
you don't hit where you're moving
strategy
strategy i got it okay let's do it you
ready yeah i think so
oh [ __ ] i should be working a completely
different set of rules here
also just i always have to give this
disclaimer because of my ego but
we have not sorry that was a good buck
shawn and i have not touched the table
yet today this is our
we're ice cold ice cold ice cold no we
haven't warmed up yeah you're saying
i like how you said that as you scored
like i'm not warm
that's a so i had i just i've only
scored one point it makes me feel better
if i don't
if i don't look great right out of the
gate i gotta make a disclaimer
okay no you don't look great scoring
right away
so one two yep there you go oh hey
hey there we go so
in new orleans i mean you said that you
met this guy at a foosball or at a bar
that had a table
jesus christ that's why you said you can
score from
the back because that's your go-to well
it's wow
it's if you could only score from the
front it'd be such a different that was
amazing i feel like okay i grew up
going to like shitty bars and
in like like they weren't shitty they
were just like you know 18 years old you
know the bars that let you in
yeah uh even in louisiana where the
loophole is you can get into a bar at 18
but you can't buy the boost here 21.
so how do they highlight differentiate
they put a x
on your hand usually okay that you
easily
spit shine right off of there and then
whoops i'm 21. so uh
but i've always felt that there were
foosball people and
pool people pool table people yeah and i
always felt that i was never
i didn't have the patience or was i cool
enough to play pool
it's a whole other thing yeah i feel
like there's like a there's like a
seriousness to pull
that i'm like we're in a bar getting
shit-faced
you're taking this and like now i get it
if you're like a pool shark and there's
thousands of dollars on the game and
you're playing detroit slim and you got
gotta take them down
and this is how you're gonna pay around
i get it but when you're [ __ ] a bunch
of 19 year olds
right drinking pictures of [ __ ]
milwaukee's best
yeah and also pool something about the
idea of giving drunk people
essentially both staffs yeah you know
what i mean
sharpness all right but like this you
see
this is quick moving you know look at
that huh
i feel like your your old prospector
voice is about to come back
oh see yeah this is where
this is where people who've got better
things to do
spend their play time well you know
what i was thinking too is um that makes
sense that we gravitate more toward
foosball as comedians because it's a lot
more um
high energy and more of an adrenaline
rush than a lot more rhythm involved
pool is yeah look at you a nice little
defensive stance i like it it's like uh
like how they say a lot of comedians um
like comedians gravitate toward like
musically gravitating towards the drums
yeah oh that makes sense there's rhythm
and like in the sciences we gravitate
towards
um biology look at you
moving the ball around okay better than
i thought you'd be
i never really know going into these
games how people are gonna be
i mean this is very scary because you do
this
like i'm trying to block your lanes here
but you gotta you got a good stance for
sure
there it is i'm the rudy rudiger
of of jesus christ that's twice from
across the all right i'm impressed thank
you
if we're playing by bulgarian rules it
would be zero zero but
we're playing by spokane rules where you
can apparently only score from the back
i know you're blocking me up here i'm uh
i'm surprised that that would even be
you can go ahead whenever you want
because that would be um
a thing because it's so much harder to
score from the back that
i feel like you should almost get double
points
oh like a like a yeah i guess rather
than like it not counting at all
it's like i'm bored i'm like giving you
the ball back like here you go ahead
score again
total accident but you see this is how
this starts
what the opponent gets one goal on me
and i can see it in their eyes they're
like
this is possible i'm a hustler i'm
hustling kelsey on camera
and then when it doesn't happen you
leave in a genuinely bad mood
oh no i i know i know exactly
no well not exactly but my my
guesstimation is
that this is what you do for everyone
you're like oh nice nice defensive
stance
oh nice nice goal and then next thing
you know then you whip out the big guns
then you crack your knuckles and it's
way out saying oh
jesus christ i felt that one in my spine
nice nicely done thank you i'm a nice
person like i
when i see you doing well my instinct is
like oh that's that's good
okay wait so how did you get started
have you have you covered this a
thousand times
yeah it's okay so my parents met playing
in a professional football tournament
oh so i am the product of like i
wouldn't exist if it weren't for
football
and then they started training me and my
brother when we were
tall and like we'd have to stand on
stools to see the topic was just
everything in your house foosball based
on the kitchen drawers it's just these
[ __ ] handles on them you're just
constantly training
there's just giant swinging [ __ ]
mannequins in the house she had to dodge
to get in and out like a mini golf
course life is a foosball table
yeah i feel um i'm glad that they
started me
really young though but i do wish i
would have taken it a little more
seriously
um because it's in my dna like i had the
you know
the possibility to be [ __ ] really
great
but then can you pursue comedy okay but
like you're
you're you're a fantastic comedian and
you you make an
you know you're like the the the there's
no you know the world's your oyster sort
of
oh come on please um but but
were you a professional like do
professional foosball players like
roll in it yeah really well i mean
financially yeah
i wouldn't say like roll in it but they
can support themselves
look at that little wrist flick yeah um
wrist there is a risk of fury
may i be so bold um so the top player in
the world is tony spreedeman
and i don't know if he you know i don't
know what his financial
status is but no like not even
hesitating you did that like
midward you know what i mean like you're
i don't know his financial status is so
impressive all right but he gets to do
it full-time like he's
right he has sponsors he he travels
around he gets first at every tournament
he's
he's amazing do you ever think though
like he just goes like
that they're just there's like a ping
pong tournament happening somewhere and
in the back there's just some hooded
fitter
hooded figure just watching like that
could have been me too
[Music]
okay so um so i just won so that game's
done you just won
yeah that was amazing that was the most
friendly almost like i enjoyed losing
that match
i learned so much we try to make it a
pleasant experience thank you
yeah okay so come over here we're gonna
do um
round two now where we basically
um draw some handicaps to make it
easier for you to beat me and harder for
me to win so
go ahead and draw a ball
that's knuckle cracks i don't know i
don't know look i want to do this real
bingo style what'd you get
looks like a red four okay i got two
so okay so with the four you get to
start with four points
so if you score even one point i lose
sounds good i my uh punishment sounds
like how the odds are stacked against
women in life
yeah this is really what i did so i
um i can only score doing tic tac shots
so like going back and forth oh that's
all there's two
there's there's another yeah there's
another layer to this so i can only
score using tic tac shots okay
and you so take four points that makes
me uncomfortable
i don't even like looking at that right
now you're that much ahead of me
even though i know it's part of the
handy weapon what's like the most have
you ever had like a straight up
nine point deficit comeback tom brady
super bowl 53 type i come back or has
like an opponent no you
you yourself ever been just like down
and you're like get it together do it
for spokane
you know yeah i think in the in some of
the bigger tournaments before i've
been down and come back but i have a
problem where i get i get second
a lot like i i choke in the championship
so did you have
and i'm sure this question has been
asked but you've probably been in so
many situations where
on this side is some like [ __ ] obese
but popeye popeye four armed
[ __ ] from twirling
yeah just you could smell the like
kodiak
tobacco on his breath just like all
right you know he like rest his gut on
like he can kind of turn this one like
that okay
can almost play almost like
play like this so it's like he's kind of
cheating but he's not
and he just has no confidence that
you'll give him any competition and you
end up smoking him
yeah and you watch like years of this
[ __ ] you like get
it's my favorite thing in the world like
he almost deflates it's my favorite
thing in the world we just did an
episode in vegas where i hustled
people oh wow and i you know in vegas
you get
girls look extra you know i had big fake
eyelashes on and like a really low cut
top and
i'd go together hi so i have a web
series where like i do things i've never
done before for the first time um it's
called pop my cherry
and i was wondering if you want to
complete this follow me and then of
course like everybody comes in and
doesn't think that
i've ever played it because you know
that the guy is like hell yeah and like
like there's his buddy right here but
yeah man do it and they'd do like a
like a dab dab slip you know some
some [ __ ] kinky in the [ __ ] yeah
yeah man
here's the secret handshake sniff it and
then watch what happens and then 10
minutes later like
what the [ __ ] man what the [ __ ] just
happened
do they ask me do they ask if you're a
lesbian after you win
no i haven't gotten that yet i feel like
there's a lot of dudes who can accept
being defeated as long as they're by a
woman as long as the woman is a lesbian
because in their head it's like hey man
if she's also into punan you know
it's like the same thing as being
defeated by another man and that's
acceptable cancels it out but if she if
she's a hetero
and she likes dick that's like being
defeated by homo
if it lights dick you can't lose to it i
feel like that's a [ __ ] logic
that some where is that t-shirt for you
to sell on the road if it looks like you
can't lose to it
anyway all right let's go okay so wait
what is a tick-tock shot
a tic-tac-tock so there's probably a
more technical term but it's like
this probably isn't to be honest okay
you have to go back and forth i feel
like there's probably
like the kneedenheimer closed well this
is called this is a euro pin
where you pin it and then you do that
that was impressive
oh thank you um all right european
remembering
okay so if you get one point then you
win this game
do it okay ready yup this is where the
gloves have
officially come off and i can score from
anywhere i just have to make sure it's a
tic tac shot
oh this makes me oh
[ __ ] okay focus
oh damn good block that was a good block
i'm not even gonna lie about that
oh my god
okay
damn it sean oh that's i'm getting very
lucky here's what's happening okay okay
tick tock tick tock you watch the
watchman
uh i did see part of it i was kind of in
and out
okay that was on purpose clearly
all all right um so i went on instagram
stories
and i was asking people to give me
questions that they wanted to uh
have you answer and somebody wants you
to talk about your um
[ __ ] your cumin story from this is not
happening oh man
that you know what's so funny about that
is the amount of cumin
people have brought me oh really at
shows and [ __ ] at live shows
because of jesus they get me so
nervous because like it because you know
it's about it's about
a spice right cumin which you know
[Applause]
you've seen in uh
kitchens oh it's kidding this is getting
intense
oh [ __ ] really just need i can't
remember scored one goal yet okay
i mean you're gonna score probably six
goals in two minutes but
and that doesn't i don't know
you keep blocking me in the front
so there's a rule can you see the rule
on the table that when i try to like go
back and forth it wants to the ball
wants to go down yeah it wants to lean
in yeah
it's throwing me off not trying to make
excuses but dude that was that
that that flick just now that you just
put into my
my my d line here that's felt like how
do you have you ever clocked the shot is
there a way to do that
like like the speed of a oh
i swear to god i was [ __ ] jesus
christ and it makes such a
like it's such a like that's a sound you
must right
i love it well also because growing i'm
you know i'm short
and so in all sports i've always been
like the setter in volleyball
or the the point guard basketball i've
never been the hitter or
anybody obviously that could like dunk
so this is like my dunk
yeah this is my volleyball spike it's
like snipers they like love the smell of
the bullet like the gunpowder after the
bullets fire
like flesh they're too far away bloody
flesh yeah like
i saw this i can't remember what it was
but i saw this documentary like after
a sniper was like demonstrating his
skills and then afterward like
smelt the barrel just like oh you love
that smell
and like come everywhere that sound is
the version of
you know what makes me nervous about you
is that you hit the ball at an angle
so you it's like kind of wild it's like
a bank shot yeah i can't um
i'm also you know what else well i also
like got
way you know you end up i mean i hate
i don't like to do it now but like
doubles foosball uh-huh
that was a big thing okay coming up and
i was of course always
the donkey at the tail end you're the
defense i was a d
that's kind of a thing that happens in
every sport i think
like when you're young the flashy
more athletic you know offense always
offense
and like the less we don't know you're
nobody ever yeah
but then defense ends up being the most
important absolutely you know
it's not as flashy i kind of think like
com i mean what
comedians we are the defense of
entertainment
you think because we all got into this
because
all our lives i feel like we were just
not really
we had nothing else yeah yeah we were
just sort of like
well i'm not cool i'm like the one i'm
the heel of all my friends i
make them laugh that's the only reason
they keep me around right um
talent what is that yeah you know uh uh
i can't i
i'm not athletic i'm not handsome i'm
short
you know what i mean and you just said
that's interesting and you just kind of
end up getting cast aside your whole
life and then you end up doing this
because you can do it
and then when you get good at it it's
like the thing people now look towards
like
what's going on but inside make me laugh
so this is all better
but inside we feel like defense still
yeah we're deep we're the defensive
players
yeah growing up uh my friends were
always the ones who got like
prom queen and homecoming queen christ i
can't be talking to you and
i'm gonna lose focus for second year but
yeah i was always i was always like the
the friend you know not not getting uh
much male attention in school god damn
it
huh well look at you see your
your friends aren't playing foosball or
scoring from the back
i want to i want to reiterate that i
have a four-point lead right now
and i am currently you just cut that
lead i think are you sure it's only two
yeah that's why it's frustrating cause
i'm like you're blocking me all right i
thought you had
at least three by now but um god damn it
i would say in that in that analogy you
are
comedically a linebacker
yeah does that make sense sure in
football because you attack
yeah you [ __ ] go but you can you can
fall
yeah anyway so i like to comedically and
that
and an analogy sense assign comedians
their place in sports
i like it all right let's see
[ __ ] oh god you're making me nervous
that looked way cooler than i intended
it to
oh see that's what i mean you hit it at
an angle so
i can't take that though i can't even
take that point i mean not even if i
score on myself
that doesn't count as i got to do a tick
tock all right i accept except
all right ready yeah
oh [ __ ]
mother [ __ ] all right there you go
um doesn't your cumin story have like a
crazy
number of views on it does it luckily
it's gotten
some good views um what is it now it's
basically like
uh i mean don't act like you don't know
down to like the exact number too
oh the number how many views yeah oh i i
i
i actually i actually do i i want to say
maybe two and a half million
that's so exciting yeah it's cool it's
like
it's it's a dope it's a story that like
happened to me
it's or it's something that happened to
me before i ever started doing stand-up
yeah that i was always like one day
i will tell this on stage but then like
you know as years go by i was like nah
it's just too [ __ ] crazy weird of a
situation i can't like
people think i'm a psychopath and then
finally
i just started doing it and uh can you
give like
the short version of it yeah i was
basically
or the longer i mean whatever you want i
gotta give the i just don't remember
it's weird it's funny when people like
want you
like because sometimes it's like a story
that people will sometimes be like
i'll be at shows and they'll shout out
like human well they really
yeah that's not cool and like it's
awesome but it's also like i'm not going
to do it
right then and there like to me it's
like it's online
it's on this like beautifully shot yeah
episode
of uh i'll think um this is not
happening
it's like well and also i think
as comics we feel like once once you do
a story on that show
yeah it's done it's it's it lives there
now because it does they do get a lot of
views
that's so funny that people the people
shout out cumin to you because my story
on there was the manicure tool story
where i
like masturbated with my mom oh yeah and
that would be such a i mean i wouldn't
put it past the people who come to my
shows to be like
why would i put your thing in your [ __ ]
did they bring you
did they bring you the things yeah bring
me dildos no
well basically i lived with it was when
i was like young
jesus christ i can't count that though
that was all for you
but i didn't do a tic tac shot okay all
right but that felt really good
wow wow it was four to nothing
okay uh sorry what were you saying
um it was basically like i was living
with
i was like early twenties i was living
with a guy
who was just kind of a [ __ ] heart
like a noob
okay he was basically like it was a guy
in the story oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] god damn it
i kneel before the throne
being knighted as official champion of
that one game
from the back too by the way a rule that
if we had played by my rules would not
count
i didn't see that coming you all right
do you want to hit me did you just do a
cumin pun
did i you just i didn't see that coming
ah i didn't
i didn't see that cumin [ __ ]
are we all right should i be worried you
look like legitimately
yeah all right you know hey you didn't
you know when you hear the t
you can tell the tone of the tank yeah
and that one wasn't made by you
because it was soft and limp like my
shots are but
i just looked right in the camera and
said soft and limp that's going to get
used
way too [ __ ] much for my liking oh
you use your stomach to move the rock
back and forth
if i just scored doing that i would just
give you the show
like there's no this table has reached
its potential
you're the new host if you do that
[Music]
so now we play a third round yes i'm so
mad you
god damn it i hate losing okay don't
wait do you never lose
so sometimes i'll lose in this middle
round when we do things like this like
somebody starts with a crazy amount of
points or i have to play blindfolded
i still don't like losing though like i
still i feel like technically i still
should have
i should have been good enough to be to
beat you still have you
ever beaten someone blindfolded
yeah that is [ __ ] insane well we'll
do things where it's like i have to keep
the blindfold on for 10 seconds and then
off for 10 seconds or something like
that okay
okay um yeah like if you could beat
people blindfolded me i maybe i was
wrong about the
you should have you shouldn't have
pursued this [ __ ] [ __ ] earlier
okay okay so all right what's third
round so now we play a game
called two ball where we each start with
a ball
we say one two three go and on go we
both
hit it you have to score both balls to
get a point you get one point okay if we
each score when it's a wash
you go to five again um that's insane
yeah it's lots of fun it's madness it's
madness it's chaos so
we um consulted with your girlfriend
because we like to make kind of like
custom punishments for people when they
come on the show
so if you lose jesus christ you guys you
see how [ __ ] afraid i just got
there's a fear in your eyes okay
palpable
if you lose you have to chug a smirnoff
ice
oh [ __ ] you really and
you monster you monster that i
share a bed with and we don't know
i don't know what the story is here so
why do you hate
squaring off ice somewhere do you know
do you know the whole thing of smearing
off icing someone
yes like if you don't it's where you you
make a rule that you
if they you could put a smearing off ice
anywhere yeah and if they see it they
have to chug it
on the spot okay yeah right so her
brother
you've her brother uh did this to us for
like
years in a row where he just smearing
off ice the [ __ ] out of us
um and it's just at any time in the it
could be 11 in the morning
any it doesn't matter on your way to a
meeting you agreed to it initially which
we like he was like
we have to agree to the rules of the
smirnoff icing world
and i agreed which means now perpetually
for life there's no end of that contract
there's no end of this contract
it's a shitty contract you got me on
christmas morning
yikes like i open a present in front of
his family
and here's the best part here's the
brilliance of her brother travis cook
um i'm gonna give you props on this uh
it wasn't the first
gift like the first gift he gave me was
like an actual like oh thanks like
i was like one of those tin water
bottles like that man and then the
second one was like
a nice pair of like bomba socks or
something i was like oh cool or a book
and it was the third one so now my like
there was no reason to suspect
yeah that the third one was going to be
a [ __ ] warm
smearing off ice that i then had to down
on christmas morning like oh yeah
it was the day after christmas i
apologize and then had to get on a
flight
yeah like we were going to the airport
later so oh it's disgusting
i hate everything smearing off ice is
urine i would drink urine you prefer
that
i would drink the guy who did this no
not him i wouldn't drink his urine but
i wouldn't drink any urine now that i'm
saying that i don't drink urine i want
that to be
a meme don't drink urine i do not
treat you but yeah like pretty much if
you gave me a list of like
five bodily fluids that i could choose
one
or a smearing off ice the chances are
i'm gonna choose one of those bodily
fluids
i hate it that much all right wow well i
played oh
i'm so excited okay so are you ready
what if i was like gonna propose to my
girlfriend after this trip to l.a
and i lose this game and have to drink
this smearing off ice and decide it's
not happening
i can't share a life with this she's
good she knows
okay are you ready yeah okay one two
three go
that was [ __ ] insane that was
i thought we were going to be back and
forth and for like 25 minutes
i was like there was a moment where i
looked at my watch i was like [ __ ] i
hope we got time
because this first round was going to be
a while that was it's
i don't immediately that doesn't happen
that often where it's
that quick but yeah it's really fun when
it does happen though
okay are you ready yeah one two three go
all right okay okay i'm gonna cancel out
the point of this i'm not gonna
all right you're making a point here i
get it no i'm mad from losing i get it
now here's what happens
all right i get it there he is hell hath
no fury
like a like a foosball player scored
upon
okay are you ready yeah one two three go
jesus i can't even
[ __ ] ridiculous this is this is
i mean i mean like props to the whole
like oh no i'm four down
the whole i'm like i can't believe i'm
losing
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] i didn't know
you could use your mind
i didn't know we were playing the
version of foosball where you could use
psychic powers to score jesus christ all
right okay ready one
two three go you went a little early on
that one
but it's a wash i'll get right all right
i'm gonna get a little
okay i'm excited
you ready yeah one two three go
oh [ __ ] almost almost almost
almost okay yeah human story i basically
lived with a very uptight dude
okay uh who hated
uh he was a i hate to use phrase grammar
grammar not he puts 100 what he was okay
um and he was just hated he hated
mispronouncing
anything when anybody mispronounced
anything so i would mispronounce [ __ ] on
purpose constantly whoa
and he that our previous land our the
previous tenants had left a shitload of
cumin
like a big-ass jar of cumin okay in the
apartment
okay that was just there right the
people for us
and i one day jokingly called it coming
and he like went
ape [ __ ] on me he was like no no no no
no
it's human and that reaction of course
was like well now i can't stop
calling it coming there's no way you've
given me no option here
and just for like weeks did it to him
maybe longer
but then it was just one day where he
was like making breakfast and i like
bait and switched him where i was like
you know what you should put on those
eggs and he like gave me this look like
don't you [ __ ] say human
don't say call coming don't you [ __ ]
say coming and i was like tony satries
which is a spice that should [ __ ]
sponsor tony
tony i'm hollering at you tony statry
tony my man
sponsorship um it's like it's delicious
it's a spice from louisiana um okay and
i was like tony satries i got
there's some in the cabinet right so i
like pulled like a bait and switch on
and then he got all excited and opened
the cabinet and couldn't find any
because i didn't have any and i was like
he's like where is it i was like it's
behind the common
and there was like a silence that
followed and it was like
our kitchen you couldn't see into it it
was like around a wall so like
there's just this silence where i'm like
[ __ ]
that might have gone too far and then he
came out holding
like holding it holding it and like
misty-eyed
like and just heaving and i was like oh
jesus christ
and he went it's cuban
and spiked it but it was on to carpet
right so it just could be walked out
into the living room it's cute
and it just went like you know just like
it didn't chat very anticlimactic he
stormed off
i ate his breakfast that he made his
scrambled eggs that he had made
absolutely and um
basically uh long story short i was home
i was off
i didn't have anything to do there was a
save by the bell marathon on tv
on tbs i believe i started [ __ ]
yoinking it
right there in the living room because
it was it was do you remember the season
why yoinking it why that verb ever
i just for any reason it's like my yoink
is my
forget about it it shouldn't be you
could join
off you can get joint you could do some
yanking i
you could i will do everything in my
power to never be yoinked in my life
but then if it depends on what you what
if you want to be joint
trust me i don't whatever that is fair
enough but that's what that's the
decimal beauty of it it could be
whatever you want
you know it could be like i just want my
husband to yoink me
and that doesn't have to be sexual i
could be like eat it i'm so dry right
now like
it hurts like i'm medically dry so
that's what being young is to you it's
being becoming like desert dry in an
instant right
maybe you don't want to be young but you
remember the season
oh my god remember the season of stay by
the bell
where they were they worked on the beach
yeah at that beach resort
yeah that the one where jesse spano
jesse spano was just not in that season
okay
that was what was on so it was a lot of
kelly kapowski in a bikini
i was [ __ ] 18 19. i was older than
that like 20 maybe jeez anyway
masturbating and as i'm nearing
climax i just happen to glance over and
the jar of cumin still
on the [ __ ] rug and as i'm
i yell in common
like almost like in reaction to him from
hours earlier going chew it
i go come coming as i'm jerking off and
as i yell coming the front door opens
and there's just a fedex guy
right he heard me
it was like ultimately like i go i had
to go he like slammed the door
i like finish up and like open the door
and he's immediately like i'm not
in what the [ __ ] he's like he's angry
and i'm like you're the one who you
should knock he's like i didn't knock
because you said come in and it was just
this moment of like
what the [ __ ] man that is the craziest
story
i was frozen in oh it was like
it was like amazing i wasn't even
embarrassed anymore i was like that's
this is amazing
this is how the [ __ ] does this even
happen am i in a movie
am i is this have i been is this truman
show was that just a movie i watched
sorry
yeah yeah um but
oh my stomach hurts and then i found out
later that the reason
my roommate got so upset over cumin me
saying coming because he had a cat that
he loved
that died his name was oh maybe it was a
dog
it was a pet and it's he named a cumin
like year and he was still like
devastated from the death and you turned
it into like i had no [ __ ] clue yeah
no clue turned his beloved dead cat
into jizz in his mind so that's that
because of that story
i have so many jars of cumin and
occasionally tony statues which i'm not
no complaints i got i can make curry for
days
and i put seasoning on everything so if
you want to keep bringing me cumin and
tony sanchez do so
[ __ ] yes find him at a city near you
okay
here we go all right you ready so if i
get this all right it's ice time yeah
so you've scored eight balls okay all
right i gotta
i gotta stay on my ground here okay you
ready yeah one two three go
oh [ __ ]
you know what's going to be amazing is
now if i have just let you do this and i
make a comeback now that i talked about
earlier yeah using two balls because i'm
actually
that skilled what if that happens right
now oh my god
that's the exact opposite happened as if
scripted
wow
i lay down my sword before thee so
here's the
the fun part um we've turned it into a
little bit of an oprah situation so i
want you to reach under this foosball
table sean let me do it you might kind
of
reach under the table see what kind of
smearing off [ __ ]
i forgot about that for a second [ __ ]
at least it's cold beautiful thursday
oh god damn it i just kind of want there
to always be a
bottle of smear smearing off ice tape
how do you even find this i feel like
it's like what flavor is going to take
it off of a tv
original yeah so do you have any plans
after this
yeah what are your plans do you have
like business meetings should we go
drink a lot of coughing
i could i could like smell it already i
want to smell it
you know what it smells like it smells
it smells like when you like would open
a jar of noxzema or like yeah
you know what i mean when you were like
a kid yeah what's this stuff my mom puts
on her face
for sure that is like noxzema juices
ah all right all right i gotta take it
down
all right this is a smaller ish bottle
11. only 11.2 ounces
is there anything you want to say to
your girlfriend
watch your back
very medicine i mean not really i'll
it'll be me
but it'll just be me and i'll be like
i'm going to you
you're about hey someone's fixing to get
joint
ew someone's fixing to get you like
one of the worst things i've ever heard
yeah
check check check check check oh like a
champ
wow this is
oh my god you are
you're a champion i've learned
from ah
you've done that so many times you have
to just do it
your tears and you're gonna have to just
take it all
it's also so funny because like you're
you're like a dude
you know what i mean i picture you with
like a giant mug of like ipa
and it's just such a you know jersey
shore
that is this that is my achilles
it brings up every bad memory of not
just of smirnoff just of life
oh my goodness like while the taste is
still in my mouth i'm afraid i'm gonna
say something racist
it's just that's that's how disgusting
it
i'll just is god if anyone's behind me
watch out i might do a donkey kick
no one all right we're good i might i
think i'm okay i think i'm all right i
think i'm all right
sean i cannot thank you enough for
coming on the show i cannot
you're a delight all right all right i'm
okay you okay
let's see i've gotten through it should
be business sportsman
handshake i'm i'm i gotta say
i'm very impressed with uh
how you pretend not to be a jedi at this
thank you that was well done well done
you're like you're like
whatever you do in life hope that you're
as good at it as she has said foosa oh
that's [ __ ] insane thank you it's a
good feeling
yeah um so plug where people can find
you plug your podcast
yeah uh five words here on comedy with
my co-host and now
arch-nemesis caitlin hook cook
caitlin hook captain hook that's what
i'm thinking i'm thinking i'm i'm
clearly she's my
you know got a fighter now oh no no
thank you five words podcast here on all
things comedy with my co-host caitlyn
hook
kate is your fault this [ __ ]
destroys my tongue caitlyn cook co-host
of the five words podcast with me sean
patton
check it out we just did episode like 40
i think so we're amazing we're we're
babies but we're
different yeah um and then uh me sean
patton i just announced
the king scorpio tour hell yeah yeah i
saw that
so exciting go see sean a bunch of dates
it's great check it out
amazing amazing comedian thank you um
you can follow me on instagram
kelseycook comedy kelseycookcomedy
twitter.kelseycook and go to
kelseycook.com for tour dates please be
sure to subscribe to the all things
comedy youtube channel check out all the
rest of the episodes
and uh we will see you guys next time
pink
[Music]
to imagine that's the best way to edit
thank you guys for watching another
episode of rissa fury be sure to pick up
your official arisa fury shirts they are
buttery soft they
feel like dolphin skin they're lovely be
sure to like and subscribe
to the all things comedy channel and you
can get the shirts at the link below
free shipping
[Music]
you